so I'm not Chris Mayo which was the
original person who was supposed to
present this
my advisees and he actually did this
study with me or I did it with him i
should say as a part of his thesis
project from the class of two thousand
seven and he sends his regrets he just
was told that he had to work overnight
last night and tonight and he wasn't
sure that he could between those times
give a presentation so anyway here we go
this was funded by the american academy
of physician assistants and the paea
education grant opportunity and there
are no other financial disclosures i'm
going to skip the study rationale
because i'll talk about it in a minute
so the current political meal you if you
will and it's sort of current i guess to
know that in 1988 we started with the
association of postgraduate PA program
so there was now a opportunity in a
forum for residency programs to be
accredited through the and then the AR
cpa well i'm sorry the association
actually was created and they began to
work together and then in 2006 they
formed with the AR cpa to start
accrediting residency programs for peed
pas in postgraduate resonances and then
in 2009 the NCC PA moved towards their
specialty certification recognition
program and so one of the questions that
we had was what was the evidence for
some of these changes and so our
questions were how often do pas change
specialties during the course of their
career and the reason we wanted I wanted
to know the answer to this question and
actually Chris did too is that when he
came to interview with us he said I
chose the PA profession because I wanted
to be able to move from specialty to
specialty throughout the course of my
career and that currently that certainly
based on my ten years of experience in
admissions here that seems to be a very
common theme that's what people say that
that's why they didn't actually choose
to become a nurse practitioner in fact
so are there differences in generations
in terms of how often they move from
specialty to specialty and if they do
move specialty specialty
how quickly are they prepared from one
specialty to the next and are there
additional training opportunities that
people are taking advantage of and do p
a's value the flexibility that we
currently have in our profession and
what are the attitudes towards specialty
training and residency so we had
approval from the IRB and we validate a
survey with several Yale graduates all
of whom had very different careers I
think it worked out very well to get
people who had been in residency trained
who had not been residency train who had
changed 12 * specialties would not
changed any specialties and all
different years so that worked out well
and then we got we obtained from the APA
a master file of classes from 1978 88
and 98 and then we sent a so we wanted
people from those time frames because we
wanted people to be in practice ten
years so that we could look at at sort
of longitudinal data and we did the
survey in 2008 so it made sense to try
to capture that we were afraid that if
we asked people from two thousand and
six or so how many times did they change
their specialty in their career they
probably or maybe they have but maybe
they haven't so we want to make sure we
had sort of longitudinal data so we sent
a paper survey much to my regret because
there were five thousand seven hundred
people and I'm saying much to my regret
it ends up that we have found that paper
surveys actually get better response
rates so we did not send a second survey
because of the cost involved in in this
but we did enter the data in one
individual actually interviewed in
entered all the data and then six
percent of the surveys were reviewed to
make sure that the data was you know
randomly that that there was accuracy in
placing the data and then we had a
statistician help us I'm sorry there was
555555 a sixty-five percent were between
the
ages of 40 and 59 and eighty-eight
percent were practicing clinically and
what this shows you is that against the
benchmark of a APA data that Patrick
shared with us a little bit ago this
sample probably had a few more males
actually than than the current male you
but essentially it was pretty pretty
right on in terms of the cohort the way
that it fell out based on the graduates
the yellow block is the graduates from
the class of nineteen ninety-eight as
you might imagine because there are a
lot more programs in 1998 and our
response rate from the so twenty two
percent the blue was actually 1978 and
1988 was nineteen percent so for some
reason in 1988 there were just less
graduates who were in the aapa database
I don't know what that means so in terms
of looking at the specialties over the
course of their career how many times
did they change specialties just about
thirty percent changed twice but you saw
that there was a standard group of about
twenty two percent or so that did not
change specialties they stayed in the
same specialty essentially the entire
time and then we had some people who
change specialties three times and more
and we actually had someone who reported
that they changed specialties 17 times I
was trying to count that I think the
point is that we used the specialty list
from the APA and that specialty list is
actually 67 different specialties so I
think that they probably were working
part time and one specialty in part time
in another and that's how they ended up
adding that up that was an anomaly that
was only one person who who told us that
so the most common specialties that
individuals said that they had worked in
over the course of the career was
primary care and family medicine no
surprise emergency medicine also had a
prominent role at about thirty percent
and then internal medicine and
occupational medicine were very common
and about twenty percent of orthopedics
in terms of being prepared for their
first job out of pho
we asked them to rate this on a like or
scale how prepared were they and most
people thought that they were moderately
very well or extremely well prepared
very few people thought they were not at
all prepared or a little prepared we did
a second secondary analysis and analysis
and the people said that they were not
at all prepared generally were the ones
who also said they didn't practice so I
don't know what that means but right so
this is very interesting this is the
time to comfort in their first job so we
asked people to estimate like how long
did it take for them out of PA school to
be familiar and comfortable with their
new role as a PA and what you see is
that more than fifty percent of people
at the six-month mark we're comfortable
and certainly the majority of people
were comfortable by the well by the
six-month mark but actually by 12 months
eighty-eight percent were comfortable
with their their position so what that
suggests is that even with the method
that we're currently using to train pas
that they are able to within one year's
time be up to speed in the position that
they're in so when we asked about
additional training after PA school this
was quite surprising to me none was the
most common response it was fifty
percent and residency on the job
training and additional certifications
and others were less well represented in
terms of certification when we asked
them to fill in what kind of
certification they had it was a CLS
training it was BLS training it was
dermatology screening testing something
else and the other actually most
commonly was a diabetes educator and
just forgot the other one well I can't
remember if you you can email me if you
really want to know I'll tell you so the
importance of career flexibility we
asked them just to rate this on as
Likert scale so not at all to extremely
important and you can see that the
majority of pas in the sample said that
this was moderately to extremely
important in terms of the flexibility
from to move from special
tita specialty and this graph shows
really the the means for all of the
graduates but what we also found was
that that was it didn't seem to matter
generationally so that the people from
1978 responded pretty much in the same
way that the people from 1998 responded
which I thought was interesting the
likelihood of specialty change if
additional requirements were required
and you can see that we asked them
questions about if there was additional
certification requirements or additional
training requirements and specifically
we said in that question in the
additional training requirements we said
in parentheses like a residency program
or something else that would would
verify and what we see here is that
there's a certain percentage of us that
would never change no matter what
whether there was something that we
wanted to do or not and not likely was
quite high in the additional training if
a residency was required fifty percent
of us said we would not change if a
residency was required and not likely a
little likely were also well represented
in the both additional certification and
in the additional training requirement
so what this slide shows you is that
most people felt as though it would be a
barrier to if you required specialty
certification and or if you required
additional training that that'd be a
barrier to moving specialty to specialty
in terms of the we asked them a question
about the importance of flexibility to
prevent burnout and what we learned was
that again this is very similar to one
of the earlier slides that said that
most felt that it was very important
from a moderately to extremely important
for their career so some of the
strengths and weaknesses of this
presentation the strength is that it was
really the first study to show with
primary source data so some of you who
saw the health affairs article that that
was written by rod hooker at all that
was actually done using
from the APA but it was not accurate in
other words if you weren't sending your
annual survey in every year not that any
of you in this room would do that but
you may not be able to tell if they're
changing specialty to specialty over the
course of their career we did see that
and it's not reported here there are
generational differences and there were
also gender differences but those again
will be reported at a later time this
there's some important qualitative data
we asked people about the barriers to
specialty change and now it was very
interesting the class of 1978 said that
the biggest barrier was that nurses and
physicians didn't accept the PA role and
the individuals from the classes of 1998
had completely different issues they
said you know we don't want to move or
they had family concerns or something
else but they didn't mention that
acceptance of the profession as an issue
and the limitations are obviously
there's a recall bias our response rate
is not as high as i would have liked it
to be although i think it shows that the
sample was representative and certainly
we were asking questions about
perceptions and so there's a subjective
nature to that so the conclusions are
that pas do change specialties that pas
adapt to the new environments relatively
quickly they value for your flexibility
and they report that they're not likely
to move from one specialty to another if
additional certification or training is
required and thank you very much